[Music]  on that point let me be clear  we have the forces the capabilities and  the attention  welcome to the white house earlier today  i announced my attention on tonight i'm  going in front of our national  the ford nominated rumsfeld to replace  james  there are no knowns there are things we  know that we know  there are known unknowns that is to say  there are things that  we now know we don't know  but there are also unknown unknowns  there are things we do not know  we don't know  we believe the intelligence was correct  it turns out that it was not completely  correct your foreign policy is based on  lies  the war in iraq was unjust and illegal  and the occupation is immoral  there are u.s soldiers  the united states  [Music]  you